are you guys willing to put in the
fourth reason what do you got for me
Steve Lamming clean so we can eat please
ok explain or give me an example ok ok
good so yep good so things that are hard
to quantify but if it's a qualitative
kind of situation very hard to hand that
to a decision support system it's
electronic and just like you said taste
just facts and figures and numerical
things ok good
are you ready to raise it up to four
smelly interesting you should say that
I'd say so how can we say this
it only takes what what what da da do
you think a decisions voices of an
electronic one could a seventh okay so
binary data but obviously we can we can
express lots of different kinds of data
in binary form so what kinds of planks
we can do audio we can do we can do
images we do text okay so we're saying
limited data times right okay whereas
for instance you know if you had to make
a decision about whether to keep or
discard some food for example that might
be getting close to due date
what's probably the first kind of data
that you use taste I ate it and if I die
well maybe I shouldn't keep it okay I
was going to say smell and get a smell
first
and sometimes you can smell something
isn't quite right before you can see it
milk for examples a classy example
it smells that before
all right